this was always going to be an emotional
Journey but even the most powerful man
in the world didn't see this coming
on his visit to County Mayo's knock
Shrine Joe Biden was asked if he'd like
to meet the Irish chaplain who while
attached to the U.S military gave his
son Beau Biden the last right as he died
from brain cancer in 2015. it was a
chance meeting away from the cameras
that left the U.S president in tears
father Gibbons the priest said then well
the priest that the priest that kind of
supported your son works here at knock
and he didn't know I worked there so
then he's in dorm for me to go and see
him and when I when I see them he was a
little bit more a bit emotional you know
we the last time we met was when the son
was very ill eight years ago after
prayer and reflection President Biden
visited a hospice with another
connection to a son a plaque at its
entrance dedicated to Beau Biden's
memory Joe Biden had turned the sod on
the center on a private visit in 2017.
it was an emotional start to the day but
it ended in a party this is the
ancestral Biden home of Ballina and
they'd been waiting for this since their
favorite son was elected president it's
good to be here and to show people that
I have met him because a lot of people
might think what are you going down for
again but I want to meet him even a
third time and the picture I will always
treasure it's strange that he's so close
to our home you know when we're used to
seeing him on television but um yeah it
is a bit surreal that would be kind of
this close to him because we've got to
see him on the news
[Music]
President Biden spoke in front of a
cathedral built with 27 000 bricks
supplied by his ancestor Edward Blewett
in 1828
as in labor I'm sure Edward imagine that
one day his family would worship here
that his children will be baptized here
like his son Patrick was
and that future generations of his
family would Mark the Milestones of
their lives here in his sturdy walls
but I doubt he ever imagined his great
great great grandson will return 200
years later as president of the United
States of America
this was a rousing end to a grand tour
of Ireland that mixed the deeply
personal with the political Joe Biden
leaves this island a U.S president more
connected than ever with the land of his
forefathers Stephen Murphy Sky News
Ballina County Mayo